hoping to have a respite from politics
over Christmas week don't count on it if
you have relatives who support Bernie
Sanders Sanders campaign has released a
family persuasion guide it gives
supporters scripts so they can shoehorn
politics into every last moment of the
Christmas season they're feeling
nauseous
there's a reason author and columnist
mark Stein joins us tonight mark thanks
so much for coming out so just just set
the scene here because when you talk
Bernie it's not like talking other
politicians here was Alexandria Kazuya
Cortez who really is one of the dumbest
people I've ever seen on camera but but
that aside
here she is it a Bernie rally cut this
is the tone they're hoping for watch
this so so Bernie wants you to discuss
the nature of our fascist Society
Arnon advanced society at Christmas yeah
are you going to well you know the base
basically Alexandria cassio Cortez is is
right that Bernie supporters think that
their parents and grandparents are
fascists racists homophobes Islamophobes
this a folks that of phobes and their
parents just think the kids are stupid
but they can be stupid in a mildly
diverting way and if it's a choice
between you know sleeping off Christmas
dinner over the prices right or
listening to your kids say that
Alexandria Casio Cortez talks a lot of
sense about how fascist America is and
why can't we Baal be more like Venezuela
where they're so environmentally and
light and they've abolished toilet paper
I don't know in terms of entertainment
over the Christmas lunch that I don't
think it persuades anyone and basically
for these what's so sad about these
young Americans is that Bernie is in
fact their surrogate father also a good
grab
I don't think there's a self-respecting
middle-aged man across the fruited plain
who wants his kid saying our man dad
you're so squaresville why can't you be
more like Barney I don't think that's a
particularly helpful message over the
Christmas dinner so I have to ask you
this you're not prepared for this but I
have to throw it out this is the last
conversation we're gonna have in 2019
2020s right coming up is it gonna be
crazy or less crazy more the same word
do you expect oh I think it's gonna I
think it I think the crazy button is
gonna accelerate
I mean basically this whole wine cave
controversy now I mean if you actually
wanted to pound thought when Obama said
last whatever it was eight years ago
look at the way the price of arugula has
gone up that was crazy but this idea now
that they're arguing about the precise
point at which you have blue-collar
credibility over the price point on a
bottle of wine is fantastic we're not at
Iowa yet by the time we get to New
Hampshire it's gonna be not so off the
charts now you're making me look forward
to it I was fearing him before but as
usually you put everything into context
it made me feel better the great Mark
Steyn have the best Christmas yeah happy
Hogmanay to you Tucker amen